foreign
[Applause]
action from Pat
so can you stop yelling Jesus Pat
um so are you booking another podcast
over there yeah yeah are you like can
you ask Bobby Lee if I can hop on too
yeah should we just do press for our TV
show together you just sent me as a
picture of his penis
just because it's Wednesday so do you
need a magnifying glass yeah I can't see
it at all that's not his penis that is a
California raisin
so the clothes pin we Mary Lynn and I I
here's how I usually start the show I've
done it twice but I decided it's usually
I start with asking the guest are we
friends and you answer I'm not gonna
answer
you know sorry it's already gone not
well
thinking about that because I knew you
asked it don't you drive it doesn't
drive me nuts when you go on a podcast
and someone goes I'm here with one of my
best friends Mary Lynn and you're like I
don't know you and then you have to be
like the thing is
and I think you know this I think you've
gotten this feedback from people before
we never really hung out really until we
just worked together
and when I am with you I feel like I
feel like I'm flying the greatest it is
the greatest what is it with you in Gray
the greatest I need to enunciate it's a
great test she came into my house and
she's like I thought your house was
totally gray have such a Charisma and a
magnetism that
when people when I am with you I don't
want to not be with you and I get on the
ride and I don't want it to end and then
when I leave your presence that ride is
over okay try to catch it if you can and
I feel lucky enough to catch it again
today and I feel abandoned quite frankly
when you go back to like caring for your
child I like your child as far as I'm
concerned is my Nemesis what's weird
though is that I'd love to take care of
you but you won't let me okay you won't
let me don't need it exactly all I need
is the fucking here's the Turtle base
in the Toronto that's where we were all
I need is the turtle vase from Etsy and
you won't buy it for me the
the Wicker stand so here's what's that
an elephant this is a thing it is I used
I used to not believe this it was a frog
it is possible to make new old friends
you just have to do it at the right time
so with you I feel like I've always been
like a like a fucking cheetah like
circling you and being like I'm not
ready yet I'm not cool enough yet but as
soon as I knew I was I swear you accuse
me of lying
I didn't say anything I made bearing yes
you did here's my favorite about here
good for you we don't words or nothing
but we're working on the show you know
we're gonna be TV show called accused
July 20. we're both dramatic actresses
we've already won multiple Awards of
shows and even out again we're both
incredible if I win an Emmy I'm gonna
have you do mine and if you win one can
I do yours
do it can I do yours like the speed I
want you to accept my your word on my
back remember when Marlon Brando sent
like a Native American yes if I would
love to be your Native American if I
will go up and piss myself like Bradley
Cooper in A Star is Born no like um uh
uh taken like Liam Neeson all the time
all the time okay I would be I'm gonna
be your wolf and follow you with the
award in my mouth okay so keep going
tell about tell us about the show well
first I want to finish my thought of you
coming up to me in the coffee shop in
the hotel
with a genuine and I believed you you
had that look you go
I didn't want to come up to you like you
had that social anxiety because I was
sitting by myself and you had saw me
before I saw you
and you didn't like wanna do you
remember that I spent about 45 minutes
pacing in the lobby after I saw you
because I because when you do a TV show
this is the contradiction of you and
then like a few seconds ago when I said
I want to take care of you you're like I
don't need it like you're you're the
baddest bitch boss but then you also
have this side that's like I didn't want
to approach you and I was like is this
is she for real right now because it
seems like you're playing a character
and I know you weren't because I was
like we I you're you're the boss Whitney
what I don't like okay so when you I
don't like sure I don't like when people
trap you okay when someone there is
everyone has the right to be alone in
public and do what they're doing and not
be accosted by someone they know if I
see someone I know in public like at a
coffee shop working I will text them and
be like hey I see you
do you want to hang or not no pressure
because I don't like when people come up
to me like Renee Jenny
Seattle
well yeah and then I don't want to
approach you because then I don't want
to be that person and I see your
Universe literally ordering urns for my
dead Mom let's I need a I wasn't ready
for and then I'm gonna disappoint you
because I'm like it's so nice to talk to
you and they're like she didn't remember
like fuck it's just like I don't I think
that in public it's like when you're
pregnant and people just touch your
belly like no one has any fucking
manners or boundaries I think you have
such a Charisma and a magnetism that you
create an an instant intimacy with
people and that everybody wants to be
around you so I try to but then when you
pulled that on me that was like so
Charming like I didn't want to approach
you and then you did and then it was
immediately like do you want to go to
the gym and then we went to the gym and
um
you kind of did a comedy act for me
while you were working out I wasn't
trying to be funny no because you were
talking about who you were dating or who
you used to be dating but it was an
anecdotal there was a beginning in
middle and end with laughing while you
were doing yourself because also the way
that also you're working out is
hilarious but you and I both do mic drop
moments for each other so I would be
like yeah because this is how my dad
died boom sit up and you'd be like and
then because my ex-husband who's like
you know my ex-husband who's on a date
with someone else and push-ups like we
were just popping bombs at each other
that's what I love about like instant
sisters instant friends you know what
we've never done
small talk it out I don't do small talk
I go straight to Big yeah you do so I
didn't want to approach you and then
have you try to talk about the rain or
what if you wanted to talk about the
laundry my laundry thing's not working
I'd be like
so I just gotta slowly
yeah and before I'm trying to talk about
the show can we talk about what a good
time we had on the show so we that's the
thing I imagine you hanging out with
other people and I'm like I wish it was
me and I don't even want to go there
because I'm not that type of person I'm
not needy so I don't need you okay I
don't need you that is Liam Neeson uh in
public after he wet his pants and takes
pictures no always oh my God I need a
closer look always uh um what year is
this laptop from the future oh the
future so yeah so next time we go to the
gym maybe more core work you're like
this is where I edit things I'm also an
editor
this is where I put my reel to reel wait
yeah so if so look the real ones the
real bab the real good for you fans know
about Liam Neeson's urination and public
problem and his pants but it's fine
we're gonna move on because it's already
been talking about can I have my moment
with it I can't believe how many
different I know one what are so here's
the thing about it I was born I was made
in a lab to make Marilyn rice could
laugh and I know this about myself so
between drew the flowers on Drew
Barrymore's clothes and the Amber Heard
Johnny Depp trial like I we were in
Toronto shooting a very dramatic
psychological Thriller show you could
ever imagine and I was doing an
impression of Drew Barrymore most of the
time whenever we were off like we I have
a scene where I am violently like
attacked and like in between
right in between I'm like yo the witness
of the Johnny Depp stand
he can't paint anymore like he can't
paint the guy is so stressed out he
can't even paint anymore like we I love
that you remember that too we had a
psychotic break basically yeah we did
you know what about when we were going
to find the handmaid's tale
set how about so many things happened
not on the show before we were shooting
next to the handmade not handmaiden I
don't know is that the UPN spin-off
and handmade in story that's the porn
the handmaidens So Stories we discover
halfway through shooting this crazy
drama in Toronto which by the way kovid
was peaking we didn't breathe one ounce
of oxygen the whole time we were in
masks the whole time remember covid safe
like just being smothered by like masks
and fear it was there was so much we
were on a drama that was already like
it's Howard Gordon who's gonna be coming
on the show he did the Americans he did
24. the writers did some of my favorite
shows one of them called An American
Crime like this is like an incredible
heartbreaking poignant smartest shit
drama and then you and I are just
straight out of the Belling room just
like like we're just like let's go to
Niagara Falls everyone's like what you
have to get up at 3am my favorite where
the Niagara Falls was another whole
moment that's time first of all I'm in
my room you don't even know what goes on
in my mind because you're so busy with
what goes on in your mind but I really
think about other people
it's called codependence recovery 14
years I guess this that is beside the
point of what I'm gonna say I was gonna
say let me wake up I guess I move a lot
slower that's all it is I move a lot
slower so I'm gonna I'll wake up and
like see if we can get a rental car and
you're like I don't know and like
seven minutes later you had no for a
second you're like should we take should
we go on a helicopter tour should we
should I get a tour of uh I hear uh I
hear the the I hear the I hear the pilot
that Kobe's guy trained is is uh we
almost went on that we almost went and
then I said no let's not
buying any tickets you have a son we're
not doing helicopter I have the child
that I need to raise and we we don't
want to commit to that okay I'm gonna
say one video for the day I I I'm gonna
say one thing Niagara Falls on the
Canada side is one of the few
visual feasts that lives up to the hype
one of the few you did you wanted to
commit to a
a helicopter but then you didn't want to
commit to a rental car or maybe there
were too many variables so you ordered
an Uber to drive us over 200 miles how
about this Uber drivers is the Ted Talk
of your life I love talking to Uber
drivers they know so much fucking more
than anything
yes we did we did because we asked if
weed was legal
I remember trauma bonding and drinking
Coors Light we did drink we did all of
them we got wasted at Niagara Falls we
got soup
and remember the woman that was out you
got soup and Coors Light because you
have to have like four liquids at all
times at all times correct that's what
happened in the morning when I tried to
take care of you and I was like oh this
is something else entirely because I
tried to call you and go what can I get
you and then you were like not having it
and then when you showed up you had like
six drinks and you were like I'm not
always like this and
um
usually I have pear juice so now do you
want to tell the story about us going
into the gift shop at Niagara Falls yes
see I'm still two steps behind you I'm
still with the glory of the Canadian
side of Niagara I still have that pizza
all through the window and squealed like
children can you tell the story we you
could see the water rushing over and we
both
yeah she wanted to buy jams she wanted
to buy like a pomegranate Orange
drink you lost your mind in the
um gift shop is what happened
and that's when I learned about her Etsy
addiction
um why am I talking by myself
this is the the monologue portion of the
podcast
what was happening that we couldn't
[Laughter]
oh we couldn't take a tour we couldn't
take a boat tour because they thank God
it was closed
and remember we watched it we were like
glad we're not on that boat but there's
some things visually like all the
Rushing Water it makes you want to jump
rush in water more like it it makes you
feel like you're tripping a little bit
and we were yelling with excitement you
brought that out dangerous the joy of a
child how violent or maybe it was the
Coors Light waterfall is that's gonna
make noise a sound problem audio issue
no no if you wear that on when you
started it I am no but I better try it
on that's got to go and you're blocking
my camera while it's a saboteur okay yes
so yes we can do this but the sound if
you take so much as a match is if you
take a bite of mashed potatoes I will
lose half subscribers like people
where's the mashed potatoes I thought if
it was gonna be that kind of party I
would have put my dick in the morning
name the reference what if I don't move
bring out um what's her name so I can
have make love her as you called her
she'd call my robot white cloth what's
her name bear claw bear claw bear claw
bear clock okay
it'll come to me I'm gonna take control
of this now I haven't made one sound
Pat and I are on neurolink look at this
color I know I thought it was thicker I
remembered it differently remember when
you made fun of me buying those jackets
yeah I had to talk to the cashier and I
had to do one of those I don't know what
what's her deal oh I actually buying a
raincoat at Niagara Falls when it's
raining out what a crazy idea no because
we're gonna get ponchos
yeah that were made of why did you want
cancer why did you want jam why did you
want to Wicker footstool oh so when I go
okay so slow down so when I travel you
can't I have you had to have everything
I go grocery shopping at gift shops in
other cities that's where the good jams
are
the best jams are in gift shops in Great
hotels the best syrup attitude you're
just out there buying the Aunt Jemima
that's been exploiting black women for
hundreds of years I'm here buying family
owned liagra did you buy the maple
indigenous you didn't let me thank you
well now that I've seen what's going on
here it's just a different concept of
life like you have this is a universe
and you got to keep it going and if you
don't buy if you don't have a constant
flow of stuff from gift shop if it's
from Etsy this is my deal clean buying
guilt-free buying don't buy on Amazon I
don't because I can't handle the guilt I
buy I try to buy as much as I can I mean
local local and then bring it back you
think the gift shop redistributes
Niagara Falls is is a local operation
not a big Corporation I look at the
brand there yes it is but a couple of
their jams jelly and I can't argue some
of them would be mama and black owned so
I have an app where I look at the thing
and I go who's the money going to it's
not going with Niagara Casino a lot of
times especially when you're a casino is
always going to be on indigenous land
for the most part you're two steps ahead
of me what am I going to argue
indigenous honey am I gonna argue with
you buying the indigenous honey of the
people also as soon as what are you
trying to say hey all you out there
getting jet lagged can't sleep after
getting sick when you travel first thing
you do when you land is what eat local
honey
oh so you acclimate so you don't get up
I'm making zero noise at all by the way
I don't know why you didn't trust me
putting this jacket on I know I can't
hear I am can't I hear static I have
misophonia in your brain yeah in your
brain so I need to buy like three things
to get that static you're not gonna take
over this interview with your charm you
sneak accusing me of being so Charming I
can't even fucking Wrangle this bitch
you're one of the most interesting shut
up you're one of the most interesting
people I've ever met she is a fucking
Bastion of wisdom I'm like 90 sure what
Bastion means I think like box uh of
wisdom I'm a basic bitch from the
Midwest and we're gonna get it out of
you because also I'm gonna say this it
pains me to say so don't thank me
I think
you are in my top three performers as
Comics dude I didn't know where that was
going that could have gone anywhere it
would have been like that make me want
to shoot myself that make me laugh out
loud when you came with me to Van was it
Vancouver that we'd perform together and
you went on a fucking rant about Gilmore
Girls or like were you just about so she
is like I did that for you she is one of
the few fucking legit stand-up comics
who also has a legitimate acting career
legitimately good can do both and is
funny not on stage Winnie my heart just
grew two sizes like the Grinch I thought
it was over for me and you just
validated my existence so how so how
you'd started your show is so fun your
audiences are amazing you're so fun
you're so generous you've cultivated
this whole audience that is legit and
it's so fun that made me feel free to do
that but it wasn't first time so did you
started in San Francisco doing more
experimental and improv don't let me
insult you with these words no please
please thank you you said
you said but why do you
think of course chocolate of course you
know about Joanna Wendt no no okay I
wrote the first movie script I ever
wrote was based on Joanna remember talk
about the performance artist a movie
called searching for Madeleine
rosenflipper I might still do it I
remember you talking about this and I
was like damn if she she did it again
based on what I took my thing that I
went to school for and you doubled down
and you said I know four times as much
as you do I don't know about the thing
that you just have time to execute it I
don't know more I just have time to
think about it and it stays don't have
friends so it's called OCD what if I
could you name everything on your shelf
yeah without looking yeah from top to
bottom or just the yeah from top to
bottom which from left to right or right
to left well it would be yours what
would this be proven because I look at
this a lot did I have good memory yeah I
wouldn't be able to know what's on my
shelf okay behind me but where do you
want to start the top shelf
hi
I'm not looking over there to see if
there are any mirrors I was just making
sure there weren't any so top top is a
Phoebe Robinson candle
yes uh uh everything's trash and there's
also a a horse unicorn stuffed animal
that has like blue and purple hair yes
right and now we're going to the right
there's one more thing on that top shelf
in between both of those two it's not a
um uh taurine
a picture of you
roast joke for free
okay
oh wait I was here okay yeah Oh I
thought I'm already wrong okay that is
it's behind here so this is what I
thought I just moved this so this I was
looking at this little pig this is and I
thought this was the thing with the blue
hair no that's good that's what this is
and then this is The Shining twins oh
shit I know but everything in here is
either integral to my development yes to
that so I just agreed I was gonna let
you win even losing so this is this is
The Shining twins okay let's go you're
not gonna do this okay okay people I
guess we could do a tour at some point
of my the studio because it's all stuff
fans have sent fans can I trade you for
this for my Tamron Hall mug um I'm just
kidding I don't want it no but I can't
you're gonna say no because I no no I'm
gonna buy the camera at home Cameron
homework Cameron fuck Cameron Candace
Cameron so why people want to know
they're I can't I can't listen to me
people tune into this to listen to
guests and then they just ask me
questions about myself and I'm they know
so how did you get so free on stage I
can't do that
I can't do listen to me I can't go on
listen I can't go on stage and be as
free as you so help me understand I have
to write everything out first I just
started writing on stage after myself
Whitney uh brought to you by better help
I'll give you half
how do you do it I'm gonna cry teach me
how to do comedy
I don't know how I have to write it down
first there's too much happening and
you'll come up with uh I cannot write it
down first okay so all the stuff you
said on stage when you were like hey
Toronto Vancouver I they shoot a lot of
things here I could play the stepmother
in the Sabrina the Teenage rich I don't
even remember that I said that fuck you
or vote if you can't remember that
I know she went on stage and I can say
it and then she goes away again I love
my favorite thing to do is to talk to
Hollywood and tell them what to cast me
and I'm like Todd Phillips Joker let's
go what do you hate money let's go fine
you know what higher I'll be Plaza I'm
saying because that's why I want to live
in Vancouver so
hire me and hire me like you're like I
and then she was pitching herself she's
like I could play like the side chick
new wife and she's the teenage the
teenage bitch reboot I talk so fast
you're like I could be in the bridge in
office like behind me it was something
that I said you remembered more I know
okay let's slow down okay then let's
let's do a how how does Mary Lynn come
up with jokes and material let's do it
right now what was the newest joke
you've done on stage recently
oh do I need to get video from The
Improv so we do you know like is your
hippocampus just trashed from doing 24
because that was all one day is your
life one long day for Christmas because
I haven't been on stage in like four
days she was on 24. maybe you think this
is all the same day listen this is good
thank you first break your brain it came
out a little bit sad but I think this is
hilarious it's not totally written and
it is let's write a bit I wanted to see
how you do it my dad
I can't remember he's alive okay so it's
already not that funny he uh but it it's
in that realm because my mom is passing
this is the first Christmas without my
mom so uh I'm going home for Christmas
and my dad um he left me a voice message
for the first time in his life he left
me a voice message I was so excited and
then his message was you don't have to
come home
you don't need to come
it was a crocodile damn
I'm just happy he knew my number so
where
that's good right but so why she's so
juicy and so funny go home
I mean yes now that I've been home I did
but it but it's hard because it was a
little bit I'd rather stay home and hide
from it because approaching it was going
to be in the house that I grew up in
going to be around all my messages okay
here's where you're up where'd you go uh
south of Detroit nice
um this lady came up to me at my mom's
funeral and she grabbed my arms
hooked into my eyes said I don't care
for Hollywood and I said that's good
because you're not good looking enough
to be in it what's up that's good right
that's like a joke joke one of my first
jokes I ever did when I did Carson Daly
I've been doing comedy like six months
and one of my jokes was about whenever
my dad would call
I mean I'm lodging the punchline but how
when like dab called like he's like hey
what are you doing and you're like oh
I'm doing this and then he'd go well I
guess I'll let you get back to that
like go what I guess I'll let you go I'm
like you called me what the fuck how did
you manage The Gaslight me and that's so
good being like how like our parents
like being very dad about it my parents
like well I was I was born to I was
conceived two months after my sister I'm
totally the accident the mistake like
there was never time for me I had to
just fit into it because they admit they
call me a surprise but it was blatantly
obvious like and so I am a burden on the
family and I have this career because I
had to make myself useful to like
whatever but it was always like all
right well I guess I'll let you get back
to that I'm like I'm just I'm in therapy
waiting for you to call me I love that I
didn't even arrive there and he's
already saying it's okay if you don't
want to come this is the first message
you've ever left me and it's to tell me
not to come but isn't that his way of
saying please come
yeah no he's happy I was there he went
yeah because he he also my mom did
everything including speak for him so
this is the first I think he in the in
reality he wanted to he was talking
about the storm and he was saying you
know I heard the weather's going to be
bad definitely so he was taking a step
dying to go home and fight with their
relatives for two days they're dying
yeah so you'd if it's Detroit you but
you also can go in a week and I'm like
I'm big on you don't have two holidays
on that day it's such a fucking scam and
I came close to canceling it but it was
fine nice where's south of Detroit
Trenton nice because a lot of people say
Detroit and they mean fucking royal oak
or Bloomfield Hills I'm from the other
side Amy Schreiber from Bloomfield Hills
she's a rich bitch isn't that one of the
wildest areas in the country luxury to
have the sexual life that she has yeah
and her dad was in a bed for 12 years so
nothing but luxury fucking just walk in
the park trust fun kid she's my favorite
so can we work I just want to work I
just want yes please let's write this
joke so it's so juicy when you okay so
you would start you go my dad said I uh
you don't have to come home so you would
start there and then what would you do I
thought I was gonna end there so that's
the setup and the punch line same line
or are you going to draw it out on stage
the setup is I was so excited that he
left me a message that has never
happened before and then the message was
don't come and then you just go and then
what happens when you get there
I say I'm sorry I made it yeah yeah I'll
be under the table I guess I'll be in my
room
I made it I'm sorry I don't know it and
he's like where's the grandson he's
there yeah son comes I'll go back and
get him did you
where's the Sun
where's your son and all this yeah do
they have they met they've met gotta go
what's the moment where you're where
I've only had my a boyfriend meet a Dad
what's the moment when your son meets
your dad is it awkward
is it like I hope this goes well
I
no it's not awkward it's because it's my
dad's new family is working my dad is so
spaced out that it's everything is
awkward so everything is hilarious how
did he get to Detroit and how did you
get to San Francisco so you I went for
art school to San Francisco yeah I I
grew up in the in that way where it's
like you don't leave I had no business
leaving I had no idea I could do
performing right that's why I went to
school for painting So then what's
ricegum what is the ancestor and polish
whoa tell me about check what's that all
about yeah Guam Keys what's that
kielbasa and sauerkraut but what's
what's the Checker what's the checks
thing a sock full of coins as a gift
Whitney if you needed to hit somebody
you will but it's roll coins the roll of
coins also your savings Catholic
Catholic statue with the gold give me
more check I need more what is the check
ancestry give you
gorgeous skin amazing skin
what is the deal with Czech people deal
with c-h-e-c-z people what is the deal
with Czech people is what this is what
you're Googling Checkmate because I'm
trying to Google in my brain because I
don't really know the check mentality
can be called a small country's
mentality small but their own that's
what many checks think prefer to pay
more attention to what is happening in
their country than the rest of the
worlds hmm so just like America
mentality of Czech people if you uh
social awkwardness common way of
socializing is to go to a local pub so
check people are socially awkward
hmm literally says that Czech people
apologize I'm trying to say they
apologize all the time at least it looks
like excuse me or pardon me are the most
frequently used phrases you'll hear the
most in public transport especially
Prague Metro Prague supposed to be
gorgeous Czechs are a little obsessed
with doing sports so in random
conversation you'll definitely hear how
some went cycling in the summer or
winter ice hockey topic always
appreciated cycling make me laugh how
checks seem rather reserved when
introduced to a new person that's
usually they don't trust people they
don't know their behavior may appear
formal the reason they may just wear
t-shirts uh sense a check sense of humor
here we go or General Life attitude may
be perceived as ironic or sarcastic oh
the same reason me I didn't know you
could get this just by Googling the same
reason goes for maintaining their
personal privacy and being a little
being intimate with people they know
naturally very polite do not tend to be
overly Direct in communication oh my
gosh I'm all these things our ancestry
tells us everything about everything
yeah tell me where scared of I'll tell
you what happened I'm also Irish look
them all up no we already know that's
just a shame so you said and then polish
polish is real simulacra energy so this
is all we need to know about the Polish
people okay did you just say simulacra
like the the illusion of something that
isn't really there but exists on its own
jumbo Gerard and and we tend to prefer
the simulacra and then the real thing
why is that about
so on April this is all you need to know
about Polish people and how they operate
on April 10 2020 that that's why I was
trying to fuck bear claw in there the
top 11 I wanted to go to the shelves two
154 aircraft operating polish Airport
Air Force Flight 101 crashed near the
Russian city of small lensk can't
imagine who down that plane uh killing
around 96 people on board among the
victims were the president of Poland
Lech
kazinski and his wife Maria
2010 oh
the former president of Poland okay
he died
the chief of the Polish general staff
died polish Military Officers Putin knew
exactly what he was doing okay Downing
This Plane
then are you on Wikipedia
well kind of yes just for this one
DuckDuckGo is I need to learn about that
so what did they do after this plane
went down
what did they do Pat
you know the answer to this they
pretended it didn't happen and replaced
everybody
they replaced the president with who the
former president his twin brother oh
oh that's good that's Poland that's
Polish baby let's go for you let's
fucking go ahead and make us you know
make jokes about how dumb we are we just
put his twin brother
no one in the country knew look a little
bit off there
down that plane
that's good my man
okay so these are the kind of sociopaths
you come from
that's right so okay so what are you
doing now besides stand up are you
touring yes I'm touring
um what and how's it going who you do
your tour with what cities are you going
to girl what I went to Peoria I went to
Colorado Springs I love Colorado going
to San Francisco I'm going San Francisco
let's stop you had me at San Francisco
yeah going for the sketch Fest at the
end of this sketchy as in that whole
place is a sketch Fest at this point
yeah the streets are scheduled you have
to do a mission people are sketchy I am
nothing fucking like it is nothing
scares me Pat what scares me
um being boring and being embarrassed
yes okay
people on the Street Homeless zombies
meth heads fentanyl uh machines no no no
it nothing's the last time I was in San
Francisco it was me and Kevin Christie
and I kind of in my head like I have a
dream about maybe living in Mill Valley
one day right outside sure uh what's
good Martin theater yes rockmartin
theater fucking Mark Pitta so so
um I used to go out to a Robin Williams
used to pop on and fucking Mort Stahl
lives there in Dana Carvey it's like
this amazing like right outside of like
a logging area if you drive you should
move in onto the Golden Gate Bridge have
you seen the documentary of the people
that commit suicide in the Golden Gate
Bridge what about Niagara Falls we
didn't see anything there they leave
their shoes and their jewelry in their
watch well what they did in those things
if you're interested in the
um uh Golden Gate Bridge documentary
they put a camera down I think for like
eight years and they caught everyone
that was pacing back and forth and
watching like what they did and how they
thought about it and if they changed
their mind and then one guy who survived
it actually talks and says how he did it
and he said that the second he jumped
she regretted it and he survived how did
he survive Pat
in pain no he fell on a seal and it
broke his fault
incredible broke his fault the second he
jumped he regretted it isn't that crazy
it's all about that I mean other people
might not have
but why did the seal did the seal know
he regretted it so it was like
was the seal like his reincarnated
fucking I don't know but that's a very
spooky I think they have Nets under it
now do they put Nets on I think they've
had to was the seal hurt
did you hear about this Jeff Ross thing
Jeff Ross went and did
um Jeff Ross roast Master General Jeff
Ross my Jeff Ross you're Jeff Ross he
did stand up you know he does stand up
in prisons
okay
um like he did a I don't know remember
what was called
um he just stand up for prison inmates
Ace Texas jail volunteered to let Comedy
Central comedian Jeff Ross roast its
inmates yes it encouraged inmates to
participate in the crowd work Texas then
used the footage to sentence my client
Gabriel Hall to death
what yes I did not see that coming
I am logged out of my Twitter because of
the hack uh so if I could click on that
we'd be unstoppable but I can't perfect
but I could go to Google ordoc.com it's
not wild I don't understand he didn't
know something
he said he basically said hey because
you're all fucking murderers you did it
right he goes yeah I did it like in
crowd work and they use that footage guy
goes to jail Andrew Schultz says or
Rogan says she persecutors used a Jeff
Ross special to sentence man to death so
this might a team of Texas lawyers are
petitioning the Supreme Court to review
capital punishment case on the ground
said the lower court used
non-consensually film footage from Jeff
Ross 2015 Comedy Central special Jeff
Ross Rose criminals live non-consensual
footage well the is it consensual if the
prisoners walked in to watch the show
and participate in crowd work I think
that
no audience consents to having crowd
work be done on them
but if you're taking are you with me
doing crowd work is inherently
um mind rape of audience members yes
right but they didn't pay and sign up
for it what else are you gonna do not
real bad on a woman the other night I
went real bad at her what happened
what'd you do where was I if you did it
she deserved it oh no and I was at
Flappers like the nicest place ever here
we go the lawyers representing Gabriel
Hall 28 year old Texas man convinced did
in 2015 fuck you Pat but what happened
I land on my feet I always land on my
feet were you throwing up I always
forget a syllable Pat knows what
happened and Pat fucking Whitney won Pat
zero Pat what happened this show is
sponsored by better help hold on let me
let me do one better quote
this show is brought
brought to you by what if I said brought
to you by
that would not be exactly what they're
asking I need to do more better help
sessions to figure out why I have a
mental block against saying this show is
sponsored by betterhelp I think it makes
me embarrassed so I need to go to my
better health counselor and figure out
why I can't say what the better help
company needs me to say at the top of
our
sponsored ad which isn't really an ad
because I would do it for free okay
therapy is
I know that when people who
want to have sex with me but never will
get to or people who want what I have or
people who just don't know me that well
call me crazy Whitney's crazy when he's
losing it when he has blue hair she's a
drug addict what you're seeing guys is
one of the most boundaried bitches who
does nothing out of obligation I don't
do anything I don't want to do I tell
the truth I'd never lie I forgive myself
when I fuck up not that there's such a
thing as fucking up as the world's
largest therapy service better help us
match three million people with
professional licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus it
is Affordable and what do we say about
affordable financially and
emotionally just fill out a brief
questionnaire brief literally and
figuratively to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist any time it
just couldn't be simpler no waiting
rooms no traffic no weird Zen Gardens no
running into your exes into the lobby no
reading a Highlights magazine no having
to look at like yoga monthly no endless
searching for the right therapist okay
this isn't dating this isn't Tinder okay
you can find your therapy soul mate fast
love is possible with a therapist I
don't know with like people I need to
get back on there learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
Whitney that's betterhelp help.com
Whitney or do hashtag whatever
tigerbelly because frankly he needs it
more than I do
thousands of medical professionals are
on ZocDoc they're there to help you they
listen like a friend they give you the
expert care you need okay ZocDoc is an
app where you can find a doctor and a
medical professional
any time of day the only thing standing
in your way is your Wi-Fi okay if you're
on some bullshit Wi-Fi I don't know what
to tell you get 4G something because you
can right away with the snap of a finger
find expert Doctors medical
professionals that specialize in the
care you need and deliver the type of
experience that you want do you remember
when you would have to like call a
doctor's office and they're open they
open it what like 7 A.M to like 8 30 and
then they break for lunch at 11 till
like 4 and then they're there till five
you know what I'm saying and then you
have to leave a message it's like for it
to to reach the reception press seven
pound and you're like I'm I'm dying I've
died of the of the bleeding I've bled
out already seven oh you're not open
cool I've just then just it should just
reroute you to the funeral home I guess
so now you have a problem as big as a
ingrown hair and as small as cancer okay
and you're
how did you not think that was funny it
was good thank you they don't
discriminate against your problems okay
you're gonna find a doctor in your area
in your network who's a real doctor and
not a charlatan Sock Doc is the only
free app that lets you find and book
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance are available when you
need them and treat almost every
condition under the sun
I just crushed the Stock Doc thing with
Sock Doc there are no alarms and no
surprises
no alarms it's just gonna jump cut from
the last line to like a cloud of smoking
yeah
choose from That's How magical it is I'm
a Genie choose from thousands of patient
reviewed doctors and Specialists browse
doctor profiles
upload and verify your insurance
information and get the care you need
I'm getting a migraine coming on guys so
I am having a little bit of cannabis
smoking it ZocDoc they'd approve go to
zocdoc.com Whitney and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find we're all
doing an impression of Bill Burr when we
do that for free then find a book and
top rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours it's a miracle
it's a game changer Gila Klein from Acer
H3 the other day was like who's your
doctor we've been going to Kaiser
Permanente and just waiting in the lobby
I'm like dude how are you not sponsored
by Zac doc everyone should be on
docdoc.com Whitney zocdoc.com Whitney
but Whitney will not mispronounce
anything oh she'll get halfway into a
mispronunciation and then pull it back
save it I won't let you have it I won't
let anyone have hear how mad she got
when I said the handmaid and stale
that's really bad I'm cutting that out
please cut it out I also was saying
Kelly Clarkson I was putting a t by the
way who's the most who's the person
that's been on as a guest in Kelly
Clarkson the most
um it's always like if someone cancels
it's always like I'm like it's the
morning of who canceled so for Jay Leno
and I just realized I'm sitting like it
was always if someone canceled or got
covered you know the reason why I was on
Tamron Hall I didn't know until after
the fact and I did it through sleuthing
was that I replaced um Christine from
selling Sunset who bailed at the last
minute because she had a saga with uh
the the guy the the award show the Emmys
oh she like went to the end she had some
other Saga with her ex-husband Chris
Shell no oh then I'm sorry I only know
Coachella no Christine the blonde I've
never had another Saga never seen it and
they all have sagas for people that seem
to only do nothing I think her Saga is
that she got bothered somewhere it
happens and then she didn't want to
leave so guess what's going on Tamron
Hall so guess who didn't bother you at
that coffee shop
Whitney have you okay I can't tell with
you I can't tell you Gabriel Hall 28
year old Texas Man convicted in the 2015
of the murder of a man named Edwin Shar
Jr four years earlier shortly before his
conviction comedian Jeff Ross the club
comic known as the roastmaster general
Club comic that come on damn come on
gosh what 25 years hey hey hey here's my
question hold on I gotta call out this
motherfucker hold on hey
who wrote this article hey
hey how do you not know who wrote an
article anymore like journalists like
want to be anonymous at this point
because they don't look into fucking
anything okay whoever wrote this I it
wasn't Mackenzie Edwards but calling him
a club comic is a little low I'm just
gonna say it
um
uh he was awaiting trial okay
so his attorney's claim in their filing
to the Supreme Court that they sent to
the Brazos County Sheriff it should be
called the Bezos County
um because all these inmates are going
to work for Amazon at some point when
they get out uh meaning they asked him
to forbid anyone from contacting Hall
without their permission he spoke to
Hull on tape Ross spoke to Hall on tape
for more than 17 minutes
according to the court documents Ross
approached a table where Hall was
sitting with friends proceeded to have a
wide range of conversations and wish
Ross repeatedly mocked Hall's appearance
made crass jokes about his race Lee
and then he must have admitted it
that is wild
and I know probably it's different when
people are mad at drag queens reading to
kids in schools but
um it when you're taping a special does
do people agree like sign a release it's
there's a sign that says if you're
entering you will be on camera and
you're consenting if you walk in here
and you think it's in your area to you
and gray no of of crowd work
I think in prison it's very much a gray
area because they're not paying a bit a
beige and textured they're not they're
not paying to get in but
the question was was the guy sitting
watching the comedy show wanting being
involved knowing he was on camera or was
he at another table like I don't want to
be a part of this and they came over and
filmed it
dude I just don't know the answer
Pat do they
do they give up their rights because
they're prisoners
it's being filmed
maybe but why but that's like it's an
extenuating circumstances that's
literally literally never happened
before yeah like it's the first time
it's like a real did you see the Pepsi
documentary okay why what we can't talk
about it it's we talked I've talked
about it last episode
you and your um rude
I have a couple uh bits I want to talk
to you about oh I watched this show
called see I just forgot my train of
thought again
um it's called hi it's a terrible title
it's on Netflix I thought I was tuning
in to watch this girl was a mule I
forgot her name drug meal what drug meal
a drug meal that's not her name a mule I
was like my first name is to be trans
species I want to be like I'm a horse
maybe she's like so I thought I was
turning tuning into a dark just this
it's going to be the story of her being
remembered stay Maria full of grace
remember that movie about the drug meal
no but I'm into it yeah that's a good
one
um and it was so it's the whole setup
and it's a bunch of episodes but then
she goes to a Peruvian prison she gets
sent to prison she's an Irish girl of
19. she's partying in Ibiza she's out of
her mind the guy gives her acid and then
goes we're gonna get on a plane and
you're gonna drop something off
somewhere she was on a plane she didn't
even know where she was going on the
plane
she went to like Mallorca and then to
Peru she didn't know where she was she
ends up getting caught gets put in
prison here's where it gets good you
would think okay the excitement's over
the show's over she got caught as a drug
meal I think she does I think she needs
to apologize to her mom immediately oh
my gosh her mom like fainted I think had
a heart attack or something when she
found out she should have put eight
siblings nobody knew someone this fuck
with this bad a judgment she was raging
partying but she would talk to them like
every week and then she didn't they're
like where is she at so they want to
hunt for her she's in Peru she got
sentences Goes to Jail
um in isolation but then when she gets
out
she makes friends she becomes a boss in
the prison not a boss like that made it
sound but like she's a boss bitch she
works she works in the beauty salon in
the prison she becomes like the um
person that's like the counselor of all
the other people and
it was very that's very cool it was very
inspiring I like that took a turn and it
made her better as a person and she made
like lifelong friends and she advocated
for making their lives better and you're
gonna see it coming but honestly I think
that like the way Israel people are in
the military for two years like there
would the best thing in the world for
any 19 year old especially white girl
would be to spend like six to ten like
months in a prison where you know
they're not gonna get like raped or
murdered to like learn how to behave and
learn the stakes of life life skills
yeah being in that brutal of a situation
caused her to rise up and her one room
uh roommate cell mate I call it trauma
privilege
and she was like her spirit was strong
and yeah she's Unstoppable she dug deep
she learned who she was awesome she made
money uh doing people's hair she learned
Spanish Amanda Knox when she was in jail
she was fucked totally not her fault she
learned languages to help other people
in prison that didn't speak Italian she
translated so they were like Chinese
women in Italian in prison stuck with
kids at home and then she translated and
helped them do their uh what's it called
when you go in front of a court speak I
gotta pay Italian anymore that's good
yeah she was this sorry I told you was
like yeah Amanda Knox light so cool so
so if you're going you're going on tour
um you're a regular in Tamron Hall let's
talk about it is that what it says on
the mug you have to understand you guys
let me just start let me just tell you
something about being an actor being a
performer I think we're entertainers we
I think it's you're gonna see me do a
bunch of embarrassing talk shows
probably at the end of January early
February I think it's kind of just like
doing Broadway at this point you're just
like oh I all I was saying was don't
make a face don't be sarcastic say
something Earnest smile don't make weird
things I wanted to see it doesn't matter
that's true white but that's but it's
fine I see it it does it's fine it was a
whole environment I've never been in
before you know where it's seen here's
why we do talk shows why we do Kelly and
Ryan uh no shade I almost I've asked
I've been asked a co-host I can see
myself hosting a show like that
um this is why we do post a talk why we
do Kelly Clarkson number one Kelly
Clarkson is fucking Mafia she's wolf
pack family we do whatever the fuck she
needs from us but
Hudson show Jennifer Hudson Drew
Barrymore these air in the places of the
people we fucking want as fans and want
to fuck with Veterinary lobbies you just
said no one will watch it those people
but I'm telling you who does yeah break
rooms oh you meant like no one that you
care about not knowing that we care
about I'm saying when people go why
would you go do that show you could do
Rogan you could do marriage you go this
is a different we're going to the people
that are stuck at their fucking desk
entertaining the people that are stuck
at their desk getting underpaid as a
receptionist at a vet's office good yeah
good people and I did feel very out of
place because that was like
um
um women who are at home during the day
because again all of her stories are
very much like girl chat pull on your
heartstrings this is my problem with
those Productions they're not clean
Productions I don't know how much
they're paying this fucking crew I don't
know how the hours
I don't know when we found out that
Ellen was just fucking mentally fucking
with people for it's like what is the I
need to know the work environment
Dynamic and I need to talk to the
fucking janitor and go are you being
paid well or how's your life I like that
you took it there because also those are
dangerous they they fucking it's there's
pregnant women there's saws there's
chemicals there's paint it's like a
dangerous you just created a whole thing
that the Tamron Hall Show is nothing
different
smelling paint fumes Cameron you're cool
I'm saying these talk shows in general
you know what I mean are what not Union
I don't know and you have some questions
okay okay I'm not moving forward until I
know how much Lauren Michaels is paying
everyone
I need to know how much the cue card guy
is getting paid before I set foot in
that place
I need to know there's child care I need
to know pregnant women can work there
you know my whole thing about Lauren why
do you hate moms yeah why are your hours
11 p.m on a Saturday yeah until noon
Sunday it's fine this is just I've been
in this business so long that I I I've
watched and seen no snitching just
watching going when I do this I'm going
to do it differently because right now
this is a inhumane it was based on the
way that it started the men did it yeah
the men that wanted to cheat on their
wives and underpay everyone and make as
much money as possible so but they were
so enamored with that process that they
just convinced themselves fucking what's
the thing the Declaration of
Independence super helpful rule in the
187 and 18 I'm sorry in 1770 great very
similar now
we need to upgrade the the fucking
system yes I see where you're going we
gotta upgrade the system like Southwest
air we gotta upgrade I think you should
leave because I think they're nailing it
it and in fact I have a meeting on the
books to talk to Netflix about a
stand-up special that is just Southwest
um uh flight attendants that don't know
where they are better to go that are no
there's no Southwest they got erased off
no I would say half of the uh half of
this oh that are hilarious Airlines
people have a type five like they
they're funny and they're wearing shorts
already so would their Netflix special
be the type five or would you make them
get it out and they each like five to
ten minutes I'm into this show we're
going to Belize just kidding
we're still going to Cleveland yeah
I'm literally like
for everyone else is like what's going
on I'm like dude mama that's because
you've taken your underwear off with
your toe with your left toe yeah
when I fly you're carrying it in the
bottom of your sweatpants and then the
bottom of your elastic
I was asked you know when you go on a
Southwest Airline and people put their
bags next to them so you think the
seat's taken and just we'll keep walking
past I'm the bitch that goes can I sit
there and everyone's like well you've
got them oh you hate a bag on a on a
chair I hate a bag on a chair you think
I'm gonna fall for that as much as you
hate a mispronounced word you hate a bad
other people want to miss Brown said I
won't let myself the handmaidens dare
you okay so the handmade itself so we're
shooting our fox show accused our our
violent drama where she plays
schizophrenic
um part of me wanted to go we're actors
can't we visit your set you know
that take videos we got so busted we
literally within 20 minutes I get a call
from like my agent at UTA he's like you
need to take those stories down
I love you you're the because you were I
I jumped aboard and I was like by the
way also I'm in the handmaid's tale
after show from last season yeah it's me
like talking to the actors about the
show so you said your agent I just was
like um we still got nowhere maybe we
just scaled the walls
ask me on the show and I'll stop
your move
you just want to be on a bed with a
woman holding your hands having a guy
hold on
for money for money for money that's
right don't forget that part for money
never
never
so I like to talk to my favorite
comedians about bits I'm working on and
this isn't me like trying to do bets but
I like because it reveals the way oh I
wanted to do my bit about being socially
awkward earlier and then you'd do yours
um but then we work on it together I was
so socially awkward I went to the
therapist I could not speak in the
therapist office
no I was scared so I just kept asking
her questions about herself how's your
day yeah yeah what'd you do after
breakfast she let me do that for a year
I went in there I spent
57.
that's not in the punchline yet
Pat I didn't say the punch line yet is
she mocking it right now
wait wait let me do that she let me do
that for a year I'm glad you like that
part see that I spent 57 here's a bunch
of comics only laugh at setups we don't
laugh at punch lines oh we don't care we
yeah but no we do I want to know what
everyone else is going to laugh at but
the setup is way funnier to me I love
that you love that how much are you
paying her I spent 5 700 that year to
help her plan her son's birthday
good right this is not a joke
but it's not a joke it's a fact yeah it
happens I did I couldn't speak to a
therapist office for sure meanwhile did
your son even get to have a birthday
party there
he does and he makes your dad didn't
even show up because you two can't
figure out how to talk he makes two
okay that is Dad's good my favorite
we're there okay so I have more
questions so that this bit can be longer
and longer how far did you drive two and
a half hours like where's where's this
person's office
uh San Diego
it was on a um a duck boat a car that
turns into a boat she was very concerned
about safety and she thought that that
was a therapeutic atmosphere to be
surrounded by water but to go from land
to water really opens up your spirit but
literally
what's going on how was your day
no wonder
[Laughter]
what was her what was uh I you know what
I would ask about
diplomas on the walls but I know she
didn't go to school for this
did she go to Comedy traffic school she
had a Scientology certificate
are sea org they're on her diploma was
uh needle needlepoint uh yeah from color
be mine home sweet home sure sure by the
way I'm basically in Color Me Mine I've
created a color be mine in my home
that's right of just Pottery that's
drying have you legit been to a Color Me
Mine yes I used to it used to be one of
the only things I would do socially with
people is go to color be mine what did
you do before when I socialize I have to
associate I know you never waited tables
what did you think you were going to be
before your community I always thought I
would be an Entertainer but when I was
poor when I had seven dollars for seven
years I did mostly focus group tests for
money and that I think I knew that that
goes straight to my well that's part of
what Two Broke Girls is kind of like
based on like me and Michael Patrick
King the ways that we were making money
focus group testing selling clothes at
Buffalo Exchange like I can tell you
every way to make fifty dollars cash
certainly in La you can make 300 this
was also 15 years ago you can make 300
cash in La no questions asked a week if
you just do a couple of the things that
I know how to do homeless people you
could be making you you're just sitting
around doing nothing right now on the
side of the road homeless people almost
mind sexual acts I don't know why but
you're just mind the sexual act I know I
almost did and then no one just had to
admit it because I don't know why no
you'll lose money because then you'll
get HPV and have to go to the Urgent
Care and get the vaccine
costume which I got at the buzzer HPV
vaccine for no reason I thought you were
gonna say you got HPV
and I got it there's a strong chance
that the vaccine causes it so yes I
probably have paid 600 over four years
for that I did get the HPV vaccine
remember that yeah I remember my son
just got it you have to get it by 27. I
didn't have any money at 27. I honestly
don't know if I've had it
you probably don't need it probably not
you don't make from a difference you
don't fuck to the bottom the way I do
hey yo you don't fuck your way to the
fucking gutter the way I did oh don't I
so I would so so if you're homeless in
La it's my hot new take you can go be a
paid audience member in any talk show go
down to CBS Radford be on The Price is
Right I know the irony sounds like a
nightmare you can I'd rather not make
money than do that the Wendy Williams
audience when I hosted Wendy Williams a
couple months ago was literally I was
like these are all people shaking from
DTS like that is the New Yorkers figured
it out for 50 bucks cash when it when
she's there it's a different audience
but when it's guest hosts No One's Gonna
fucking show up for me if they're Wendy
Williams fans I barely could be there so
you're saying they don't give drinks to
the audience and when when do you
believe I don't think so it's 11 A.M
right shout out to Krista Stefano
bombing on Wendy Williams so funny it
was so much funnier than killing oh I
saw clips of that he was literally just
shoveling dog shit in his mouth it was
so funny yeah he was just like doing
jokes jokes and Wendy Williams if you're
not her you just want women should be
able to be any size they want yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's all they want you just
have to talk Michelle bateau killing it
knows exactly what to do and he's like
dope dope joking on baby blood and
they're like what why did he say it
because he's a comic he was just being a
fucker he's like oh okay I'm sorry all
these meth zombies look it up online
it's brilliant so can you believe we
have not talked about the show yet
yeah
I can that I was very excited because I
just watched it before I got here is it
the link that I sent you
or did they send you they sent me one
when because the link that I would have
said mine had music really can I watch
yours yeah my mom was dying I was
texting with Howard Gordon showrunner
the brilliant and I was telling him like
this performance in this show for me
like I get to like make my mom Proud by
her do it before she dies in it you're
really really so good and and I S and I
got to show it to her but with no music
so I was like this is a little scary to
watch yourself with no music actor yeah
why did you say yes to it tell me the
process this is a six episode Anthology
series that battle that battles that
takes on
pickles problems that are like almost
impossible it's like a Rorschach test if
you think the person's guilty or not yes
you know
um I
heard about it I knew it was based on
another show and you had already worked
with Howard on 24. yeah Howard's my old
boss and I heard you were involved and
then I heard what the part was and I
said yes I'm in do you think I should
have done it I still am on the fence
like in terms of like
I'm it's about a comedian but I'm
playing a comedian that isn't me but is
kind of me when I was 25 kind of
I mean I think you've got to be prepared
to have some conversations about why you
did it and what you thought about it
because it is very close to what
actually happens and happened with
people that you know and not only but I
think that for me and then sane the
writer brilliant Sonny Hoffman it was
also like
what this is about I don't think it's we
can say it's a sexual assault and it's
very well done the writing of it the
directing of it I've never act on
something
even me and by the way every time the
casting didn't work out the way we
wanted for the guy that was my assailant
and played a community
oh my gosh he's so good so Sean but it
wasn't initially going to be it's like
there's a list online of all of the
famous parts that other like Sandra
Bullock was going to play Hilary Swank's
role in Million Dollar Baby like I think
one of Paltrow was gonna be Hilary Swank
in Boys Don't Cry like when you see the
things that you imagine no I mean I love
that movie so much and there were
amazing act like Toby kebbel I really he
was in the female brain with me I really
wanted to be a couple for this part but
like it wouldn't have worked I now see
why and he was unavailable but like Sean
because he's in real life the nicest guy
an activist most conscientious married
to a gynecologist like he's
because sometimes you get in there and
you do some kind of scene a rape scene
or a assault scene and you're in there
and you're like wait this is actually
like a lot of actors take it as the
opportunity to get like a free pass
under the guise of what we're just
acting yeah it it always it should feel
like acting it shouldn't feel real yeah
and like I wanted to feel real I'm like
why do you have a boner why is you
you're not we're not really fucking and
then you're in a weird situation because
like you don't want to be the snitch did
you guys do that scene in one afternoon
or did it it was one it was like we did
the party scene one day and the whole we
did it we had like 12 hours or something
to do that scene it might have been the
full day it's pretty quick because I had
the way it's depicted but every I know
that's a bummer I think because it's on
Fox watch the show succession if you
want to know how Fox operates but um but
you don't need much to Telegraph what's
happening I thought it was really I'm
bummed I wish they showed more of the
rape but I wish they had shown more of
the fine the the sexual assault scene I
mean that's probably what you're gonna
think when I say sexual assault what do
you think when someone says sexual
assault this is a big problem with me
too
um rape rape see I don't always think
that sexual assault sometimes I think
like
a guy at office pushes you up against
someone oh sure sure and just like grabs
your tits and it's like I know how to
make it oh you're saying sexual assault
can make it sound lesser than rape I
think so
I don't think I but I might be off it's
like no I agree with that when people
like rape is much more specific
word that may be less scarring or or
lesser degrees my brain whatever it is
autism whatever blah blah I need you
people to be very specific so I think
and I think we all do and I think that
words matter and I'm not like you need
to say this and this instead of tranny
I'm not talking about those words like
they do matter but like that's not what
we're talking about right now I think
that
the reason no one gives a fuck that
priests molest kids is because the word
molest
we all think just kind of like oh like
diddle butt
what do you well I don't think a
priest's dick in a baby in a toddler's
butthole but if that's what it is we all
need to stop what we're doing right now
and go get them out
you know what I mean of course you have
you unless something is spelled out for
you and that's one of the reasons why
this show not to say this show is
important but these stories are
important and that's that's what's
important about storytelling because you
take the time uh to really show in this
case this woman and what her comedy is
like and how quickly it's misconstrued
and I love the scene when you put shove
this stuff off that we use sanitize it
by accident like it's already super
compelling but then the moment when
you're with your was that um what is the
thing I pushed off you just pushed off
his desk because he says
um yes you can't go to the prosecutor so
I am who's supposed to be uh fighting
for you and I also love the moment at
the beginning of that meeting when you
go well we didn't cover my rape enough
and yeah and he's like just stares at
you you're like sorry you're kidding
perfectly this is the way I describe the
show
perfectly fair and it is my character I
believe the way that I approached it was
this is the
um people need a perfect victim when it
comes to women
right so if I get raped and I've slept
with the person that rapes me before I'm
out
right no one can feel sorry for me
you've already well you've slept with
them before it's been consensual right
so you can never be raped if you've been
married or if you're crazy or if you're
I think the biggest part with her and
tell me if I pulled it off
is I wanted to make her cringe I want to
make her a cringy person
which I used to I think be like
desperate like let's go to this party
and let's like I like she's 40. and the
way she dresses the dude the costume was
a the costumes are incredible but it was
a whole I mean she's kind of crazy she's
very lovable she's very lovable but
she's also a little like like
childish for her age and no one really
takes her she's not that funny I want I
the biggest thing I did the thing that
was scared in the rape scene is I did
stand up as her
and I wanted to make her intentionally
kind of too dirty like the jokes she's
doing are about like fucking her dad
that
um put her up for adoption so that she
could finally feel wanted by her dad it
was like that type like
cringe crane cringe because you want to
go like she deserved it you want to see
if the audience's brain will go yeah she
was wearing the orange skirt fishnets
like yeah Raper who cares she doesn't
matter she doesn't count as a human like
I love the way I don't love the way we
dig humanize and then your character I
gotta be honest with you I think I did a
pretty good job in my performance with
this you're so great I hate it when
actors talk about processes I don't even
identify as an actor really but like I
just fucking fully went there and I can
disassociate because like I was molested
as a kid like I know how to disassociate
and totally just be there you're not
supposed to do that you're supposed to
act but I don't know how to act I only
know how to just like be in that
situation so like so you're saying you
were able to call that up I don't want
to say what I imagined but like there's
just one thing I had to imagine and that
was it
that was from your actual experience but
nothing to do with being raped I think
that is acting maybe you're right yeah
but there wasn't like I could turn it
off like you you would notice when they
would say like action I'd be like give
me 30 seconds before an action I also
know a lot about how to make a show so I
knew how to claim my space and I knew
how to say to the like wardrobe people
hey can in between you and make up like
in between can you just like let me yeah
you know so you just because even if you
do as an actor get into this Zone it
goes cut and people go let me do your
makeup distraction distraction
distraction and then I was like I can't
have those in between just let my makeup
be bad I'm just gonna have to look
fucking ugly on the show like I have to
yeah you know but you I'm like
it's blowing my mind because your
character
is nothing like you nothing like me I
don't even know what you did
I got excited watching that and I don't
usually watch myself and I don't like it
and I'm also like I don't think I'll
ever get an acting job again and I
watched that and I was like oh I like
this I actually like working and I was
inspired by you every second and I
watched you fake it so what did you do
same thing you did
um
so this is someone who like fiercely
protective get that
yeah deeply wounded by a past thing
there is a monologue that she does about
her past trauma as this character and it
is like she says it as if she's writing
a grocery list
why did you do that why did you make
that choice
um
check check as in literally check check
your she's checked I'm checking she's
checked I don't even I don't even I
didn't think you're gonna ask me that
and I don't I know why I did that
I just imagined what if I was that lady
so it was just Instinct you don't even
think about it it's just pure intuition
that's an answer no I wouldn't say it's
pure intuition it was definitely a
choice because I have a playlist
for the character and a perfume that's
only for the the character oh no I
didn't do that okay that's how I just
try to make sure it's about an actor I
am I have to get all that this is
Brenda's playlist but similar to
Brenda's playlist which that's awesome
okay it's similar to how you're saying
you're really calling something I
there she here she is
like literally I was doing this between
scenes
no joke
I can't Jam honey jacket I mean
this is is this how you get to Brenda
[Music]
[Applause]
what else do you want
[Music]
do you know it pat
let's go
oh I knew it but I didn't have that
question the day of the rape scene you
ready
yeah there she is oh
[Music]
is this
the Goo Goo Dolls
oh it's Tom Petty's
oh my god wow and then of course
everything
she dated a couple like oh Brenda yeah
who two told her about this she dated a
couple like drug dealers
[Music]
this is like all Chappelle listens to a
backstage
oh and then of course
oh how about this
[Music]
yeah
handmaids and a handmade her story
handmaid's Tale soundtrack
when June I can't
this was main theme
oh my character's playlist is like Sarah
McLachlan Ani DeFranco that was yours
you know you know who I think was on
your characters playlist
me
and a gun oh and a man yes on my back
Tori Amos yes
total Tori Amos haven't I followed Tori
Amos to like four or five cities the way
she did you really plays piano so sweet
giant fan Fiona Apple my only blind spot
is Fiona Apple but I do know she dated
Brian Callan for 10 years
so did Patty Jenkins wild
is that true
Duck Duck Go
go
try me have you heard of this book
called Know My Name by Chanel Miller
I had to look it up so I didn't know why
why I didn't handmade her's tail that
one I don't know about this okay you
know what I already like it do you know
why why do I like it pat look at the
cover
this is what wabi-sabi is it's when
something breaks the so so the whole
theory of wabi-sabi Japanese philosophy
that after something has been injured
hurt it's actually more valuable I.E the
the girl the mule drug mule she's better
now scar tissue is uh stronger than
regular tissue so this smart this is a
bowl that's been quick this is a bowl
that's exactly describes that book it's
been cracked and then it's uh the in
wabi-sabi they fix it with gold her
writing is impeccable and she takes you
through it's when we were talking about
when you were saying sexual assault
versus rape why don't we know she takes
you through that she was raped on campus
and she had to go through this grueling
where they propped him up because he was
uh an athlete and they tried to treat
her like a drunk girl at a party she's
Asian and she's Asian and she describes
what she went through in the in between
times and she describes the trial she
describes when it happened but her
writing is is but also beautiful isn't
it amazing that if she wasn't a
beautiful writer no one would care about
her story you have to have some crazy
gift
in order to break it through can't write
can't speak well like and that's who
they pray on that's who they pray on
someone that they know can't
alchemize the trauma and out them but
this bitch had a fucking secret Talent
and then they and then that's the main
thing is people go I have a complicated
relationship with men that only date
Asian women because they're kind of
going oh in their culture they're
submissive like they value being
submissive yeah it's not taking
advantage of them or hurting them they
like it but what they don't know is that
Asian women have this wabi-sabi
mentality and they're always 10 steps
fucking ahead that might be one of my
favorite books I've ever read now I've
only read five books in my life and
she's gorgeous which is like um she's
just love it by the way I had a scene
with Jeffrey Tambor on the Larry Sanders
show where we made up where we made out
and that we shot that make out for like
four or five hours and when you see it
it just reminded me I'm jumping back to
two seconds yeah and I'm like what about
all that making out we did no so you
make out for a day go on you're talking
about it's seen on camera for 30 seconds
yeah that's why I also know what the
audience looked and I have to ask a
couple questions from the audience
because I'm we're hanging out but but
also real quick 24 did you have the best
time
that was the biggest show like it was
before lost right it was like 24 was the
first big streamer show that was like
the people couldn't watch it fast enough
I kind of relate how you said why did
you do her speech just like she was not
emotional at all in this show I had a
similar thing in um 24 where the
character yeah where I was trying to
imagine myself as this character and
that show starts at a level of intensity
and then just gets more intense and it's
not intense to her exactly and so I was
like what am I like what what would I be
like if I was ahead of everybody
uh everyone's asking me questions
bothering me not listening to me and so
it came off as this
I you're just like yeah I tried to
imagine she's not reactive because she's
got other dogs she's in the dark going
and this woman is not typically reactive
she's compartmentalized it in such a way
nothing can so there's something
fascinating about people where their
lives can't get any worse so there's a
freedom and the traumas behind me so
everything is kind of old hat like oh
I'm gonna go do this thing and I'm gonna
go it was very
what's it when something's um autism
when something's like nonchalant and you
didn't have to think about it much when
she decided to uh think about revenge it
was like I'm gonna go to this thing
it wasn't like a big deal
it's also putting it away so she doesn't
have to relive it so I also
you see you reminded me I did put some
thought into this that it's it's as if
there's an ego to
um yeah I don't want to deal with that
and so I'm going to present myself this
way because that's what's what's her
deal too of like oh well you posted this
so da da da da so I'm gonna make all
these other connections on your behalf
and you're like what why would anyone
ever do that well she will because she's
got a different it's feral it's an
absence of socialization we go oh yeah
well they told me to do it so I did it
it's like you go no but if you've gone
out in the world like that's what I try
to do with her she's feral and she only
socialized in foster care with people
that saw the world backwards so it's
like just do the opposite of what
everyone else is going to do and like
once you've found someone that's in your
wolf pack they're your Alpha and you do
what they say this is so interesting I'm
like tripping out because now I'm
relating her to you in real life and my
character to me in real life because
when you said Pharaoh I went no no
mine's not feral but mine's feral in a
different way I keep it inside and
that's why I'm like and you externalize
and then your whole costume check it out
is the least feral looking person on the
planet beige camel she's gone feral in
her own mind uh and then when she acts
out everyone it's like and in her mind
the future of humanity rests on her if I
do this Revenge it gets in the news
every woman is safer yeah she's thought
out this plan
this is the perfect opportunity need for
what I call the Silver Bullet Silver
Bullet changes the Paradigm everything
this guy is famous it's huge in the news
if I do this now yeah I go to jail it
sends a message to fucking everybody and
I make a mass shaming and every fucking
man is gonna think twice now that's
right this was her moment in her mind it
was like I'm a superhero the wave came
she's been waiting for the perfect wave
and this was it yeah this story this
girl
I think everyone in prison thinks they
did something heroic but you can't tisk
tisk do these things they're illegal but
in their mind I'm doing to feed my kid
I'm doing it to protect my niece I'm
doing it to fucking get my mom in a
nursing home I'm doing it to like I
don't think anyone unless they're
sadistic or in Psychopaths of which
there are many
like right no one signs up to be like
I'm gonna go to jail today because I
love jail they're like I'm gonna go
protect I think they all think they're
either protecting or fixing or and it
also comes down to what you're talking
about with like the decision for suicide
in that moment so you so in her case I
think she's premeditated it majorly
she's like oh but there's always some
people or that go to jail because they
made a wrong moment out of or they did
wrong they didn't follow through this so
my thing is like my therapist now it's
all co-signed and it's locked up maybe
things will be fixed by then but it's
like my main thing is that when I'm
pronounced terminal there's like three
or four things I'm doing right away it's
going to handle the fucking fishermen at
The Cove in Japan that do the dolphin
thing it's getting a couple elephants
out and revealing a couple and posting a
couple things that I can't post yet
about why zoos are so abusive there's no
such thing as education and there's no
such thing as conservation and zoos none
of it's true good people work at zoos
they're just checked in when they can
but none of it's good so it's Sea World
100 there's no what's your take on a
type someone like the Tiger King Tiger
King is a criminal some sadistic like
disgusting the people that are in the in
the exploiting okay so I helped shut
that down and uh Carol Baskin maybe she
killed her husband I'm sure she had good
reason my thing is when someone commits
a crime I go
let me just hear their side
yeah I mean my mom used to bless her
heart she's dead now I think when
and tell me if you relate at all I think
when you lose a parent where you kind of
can only focus on their limitations or
the things you didn't get from them at
least in my experience once my mom died
I freed up all this bandwidth to only
think about the amazing things she did
yeah and I and I'm actually feel closer
to her than ever when she was alive
because I'm like oh my God I could now
that I'm not scared or judging myself or
or trying to get something from her I
broke wanting something that's when you
can break the ancestral curses right
because it's the spell because I was on
the spell of I need her attention I need
her love I need her to love me I'm going
to show her this interview and I need
her to love it I need her to say I need
her to say I'm pretty like I just needed
so much from her
childishly but then I go like my mom
when I was a kid I used to fucking kick
and scream I hated it she used to take
me to prisons around Washington DC and
we would visit wrongfully accused
inmates that she worked at
Bloomingdale's and Neiman Marcus She was
like my mom like ran PR for
Bloomingdale's Neiman Marcus so like she
opened the Bloomingdale's on Madison
Avenue and all her friends and all of
our friends were the gay men the window
wash uh Window Washers the window um
fucking dressers right they made the
Christmas trees in Neiman Marcus like
the fucking most gorgeous shit right in
Bloomingdale so I grew up in in
um department stores and I was like an
informal model and perfume girl when I
was like eight I think this is why where
I got my confidence and became a
community marvelous Mrs maisel because I
don't let's not
I knew that was gonna
get you
do you have do you need to go I mean
like what so you know she was a perfume
and makeup girl okay go on uh-huh I love
her so much I love that show so much
[Music]
who wasn't
she's such a good comic I just have one
okay I just have one question which is
so what if I rate to just dead inside oh
okay okay
put down the scissors
I've been eating cereal and I'm mixing
magic spoon because I have so many boxes
of it the fruity flavor I do like the
blueberry and I do like the chocolate
but I've been in the fruity mood I used
to love Fruit Loops Nostalgia and I've
mixed it with a little bit of like a
Bran cereal so that I like my I've been
eating a lot of chocolate and my I need
to move things along and then I've been
putting apple butter on top or last
night was
um Pat's uh uh jelly
this is so weird and I have no guilt so
magic spoon I just introduced my sister
to this she lost in her mind delicious
and high quality magic spoon okay
replicated your favorite childhood
cereals to taste good but each serving
contains zero grams of sugar zero 13 to
14 grams of protein and 4.5 net grams of
carbs I added on top I also put some
eggnog in there four to five
what I say 4.5
okay that's between four and five though
4.5 is between four and five
it varies
I don't think it does
I'm gonna I'm gonna give this one to you
okay so I'm gonna back off on this okay
so between four and five four four point
five is between four and five
it's probably the they're saying it's
the average I just improved it I like
your way better
you know yeah don't get me started on
the mean the median and the mo i you've
identified the part of the copy that
needed to be abbreviated that should be
0.5
unless it's 4.8 in which case just say
that
so has this been measured or not it's
not that consistent sometimes it's for
sometimes it's five maybe depends on
what you put in it like to drink with
like milk or whatever yeah
wholesome
it's a keto thank you Pat you handled
that well
I'm impressed
keto friendly gluten-free grain free soy
free plus it's only 140 calories a
serving son's nag it's like there's
magic in every Spoonful
head to magicspoon.com Whitney to grab a
custom bundle of cereal try the magic
for yourself and be sure to use our
promo code Whitney at checkout to save
five dollars on your order if you want
to do promo code you know
scissor brothers or
call her daddy I think she needs the
money
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal guilt-free that's my brand uh at
magicspoon.com Whitney and use the code
Whitney to save five dollars off thank
you magicspoon for sponsoring this
episode love you miss you
don't cut off your beautiful ponytail so
it's I stand with Ukraine but it's
Russian I um
your mom the prisons that's wild I just
make can I wear a model yes please just
one question just because we're
why does that show not have one comedian
on staff at all don't want it not one
uh I don't know whether their staff is I
guess well sassa was maybe on it
Jen Kirkman didn't she right she wrote
on it okay I think so okay
I don't even know how I know that I feel
it
I don't know I don't know if that's true
I feel like she may have I'm just
curious why no female Comics not at one
of the 50 that live in LA or even
getting paid to
wait I don't I don't know who the
writers are on that weigh-in I don't
know how much well Amy sherman-palladino
we fucking stand Amy Sherman Palladino
the show she did Gilmore Girls she's
incredible and she's a huge huge comedy
fan she does her work when we I guess
I'm just a little bit in a place of why
are we not hiring comics
young up and coming Comics to just like
write jokes for these shows for the when
they're doing the stand up who's writing
the stand up some Harvard Lampoon
fucking nerd
okay yeah there you go got it put the
scissors down
give an exhale they're not sharp enough
don't worry I'm a little bit wolf pack
mama bear with let's start
redistributing wealth if you are making
a show making a ton of money off of a
female comedian's experience and how
hard it is
there's like 30 door girls at The Comedy
Store that could use a thousand dollars
a week just to write jokes for your
thing even if you don't use them
okay fair fair that's fair yeah you're a
model where it's perfect if it's
hysterical it's historical I had to go
up to people and go like hey would you
like to try the Chanel Number And
everyone's like like I was just so
rejected for so long by people because I
was like trying to spray perfume with
them that by the time I got to Hollywood
and people were like no thanks no thanks
I was like no problem like like I have
no capacity to be hurt by rejection but
you also before you were uh in a
position to be rejected you also knew
you had something to offer and you
believed in yourself and your yeah
chemicals from China that I was holding
no I'm saying your comedy you believed
in yourself
or whatever not so pretty are your
writing yeah I need what you were trying
to sell I needed to practice yeah I I
didn't I needed to practice like you
weren't afraid to approach people and
sell to them and and I knew I could see
that's my thing I'm afraid of everybody
I'm a car salesman though I can sell
something
anything I'm snake also okay
so at the time I don't think that you're
saying you weren't even necessarily
going this is so good you're just you
were just Full Speed Ahead if a product
is worth buying you don't have to sell
it you know what I mean like they'll go
get it at the store
if they need it or want it okay so so
now I go attraction not promotion
gravity you have to come to me only
because if I'm going hey if you're
peddling oh you're saying now if you're
the best products don't have vacuum
veins
you know what I mean
I don't need to sell myself if it's a
product worth buying
they'll just come to me I feel like I
have to learn how to be a salesperson
because I've lived my life and my career
going like and I put my nose down and I
go let me just try to do good work and
that'll lead to more good work and it
has until it doesn't and now I look back
and I go oh I was afraid of everybody so
all those jobs and all those relations
should have been because they were
dangerous all those relationships that I
should have had are I just let them go
like I let the job go because I'm I'm
like I don't want to bother you I just
I'm gonna go and audition but now I'm to
the point in my life in my career where
I'm going I don't big dick energy man
why do I have why am I starting over so
my thing is you would call your agent go
hey these are the kind of roles I want
to play
so I want to be in a room with this
casting director and this casting
director because I'm unclear because a
lot of people I've been on the other
side your name comes up I know what
people say they go isn't she busy like
isn't she kind of wait isn't she more
comedy girl you want a fucking drama
yeah yeah and then I go wait a second
the fun the best dramatic actors are
comedians because then we play it
straight
I think I'm gonna give up acting
that comes I really wanted this part
recently in this challenge we're getting
you a part on maisel your favorite show
oh my God I could not be on that show
though because I I can't yeah because
you're a comedian and they don't hire
comics
oh
how many times
um her agent is a comedian
Alex washing Borstein is a genius right
love who's comedian she's on that show
yes
yeah yeah
he's more of a comedic actor there's a
difference stand up I'm talking stand in
audition to play this if they didn't
perform at Penguins 12 years ago on New
Year's Eve it's not a stand-up comic is
it kind of sick that I wish I was
performing at Penguins this New Year's
Eve this is sickness I don't have a gig
on the ears there's a part of me
um I want to go see that it's just I
want to go see that Elvis impersonator
again it's just this so um uh I thought
that me having slept with a backup blue
man was oh a lot I didn't know that how
do you think you talked about that on
the pot how do you think this how do you
think he rubbed his body all over it
this was the fuck room he's also a
painter
fucking he bleeds blue
he went to Duke
basketball player so um and the guy from
shape of water so and by the way this is
the Weird Science uh kitchen
so this bitch fucking wanders in my
house and it's just drops casually
buries the lead that she just slept with
an Elvis impersonator it was like the
best the best sex ever you've ever had
because when someone is very good at
impersonating like they're actually
really good and not cheesy but was he
impersonating how Elvis fucks or that's
how he fucks no I'm saying his attention
to detail
brought it into the bedroom how detailed
is your pussy how complex it is so
detailed it's like a watercolor painting
okay he got down there and painted some
watercolors okay on my pussy so
it
the sex lasted for a really long time
and he kept asking like what do I want
what do I like and then he was asking so
much by the way did you know the answer
here's the thing everything was good
because I haven't had sex with another
person and was it hot because he was
asking or doing the things you said once
he asked this is a whole can of worms I
know it got to the point where I said I
need you to ignore me like I need you to
pay less attention to me that's the only
way I can come because you're paying too
much attention to me then stop looking
like that hey what's up no but I will
tell you that having that experience
really gave me a pep in my step for like
a whole week afterwards I was walking on
air because I was like it also gives you
data that there are people out there
like that and it was really good I'm
really sweet and I hope there is let me
just what's his credit like let's just
back up a tiny bit is there any
uh have there a bit have there been any
PayPal requests or venmo requests from
him yeah no he's a legit he's a legit
Powerhouse in his own right we haven't
talked since so him and I need to also
you and I need to talk about the
impersonator movie that I have uh going
because I'm obsessed with impersonators
have you seen the doctor did I just cast
him in your movie I'm I'm gonna hold uh
I need more information he'll read he'll
read okay
I'm his agent now I do he is an open
invite to the podcast by the way that's
the kind of psyche I fucking live for so
there was a doctor I was like he also
plays Prince and Michael Jackson there
was a is that everyone entered no okay
because people that do more than one
impersonation usually one of them is
Queen Elizabeth and she just died so now
they're only doing one they took out the
part where the ladies are yelling
I don't know they're not they're not
chanting like you have to understand
that was interesting because it felt
like too much in the moment we like just
seen them like that was when you shoot
TV shows and movies we see we shot
probably for three weeks straight and
they end up using 54 minutes so we're
like as we were in there and that court
scene at the end we were all like this
is fucking
this tone is not we don't know how to do
this it felt Broad and we but the way
that it was cut it's like I remember
even and I'm going to talk about this
with Howard and even sean we were like
this feels like I didn't know how to act
it like I did not know how to talk to
these it was like I was like I need a
time out I don't know how to do this and
make it feel real like I'm I feel like
I'm in bad Community Theater land with
my acting right now because like but
it's when extras come in and they don't
get a chance to rehearse they don't get
a chance to act with us and so they're
just like you know it was also like
seven in the we pulled yeah we had
because of covid and we couldn't be in
the same room the fact that directors
couldn't be in the same room with the
actors she just had to get up and go
back and get in it took forever we and
then that was the day we were going to
fucking Vancouver we worked 27 hours
straight or something got up yeah
remember at 7am and then we went to
Vancouver at like four and then did a
show that's got a real dose of Whitney
you in the morning after shooting that
and then on your way to do stand up
did we sleep on the plane
no you don't sleep on planes you do take
your underwear off and put it in the
just to break just to call that back in
the cuff of your uh yeah yeah
I probably slept on the plane that's a
long flight no you were because we got
there and napped remember you were
apologetic because I was uh following it
I was like yeah we can because you
didn't get the piece of paper from the
thing
I didn't have my fucking work permit you
didn't have your work permit so we had
to but I felt so bad for you because I
was like hey girl you've been on like
three hours sleep but you were but you
were still in the mode of like I don't
want to like I don't make you wait I
don't wanna but we went to the fucking
customs office
in the Toronto Airport
I'm put me in a fucking cage with that
whoever runs that airport there was an
immigra because I didn't have how the
fact they let me in the country without
a work permit and I was like you can't
be here you're gonna work permit I'm
like well I sailed through customs and
no one said anything that's so weird it
was weird and I had someone with me like
a chaperone because they're like we know
she's gonna fuck this up and he fucking
shit the bed too so I was in the country
and they're like we have to send you
back like this production is going to
shut down if you don't get a work permit
I'm like why are you telling everyone
about so fucking said hey I'll just pick
it up at seven in the morning
I had to drive back to the United States
and come back into the country in
Vancouver can't believe you did that
I mean this is some grit to get my
whiskerman grit right here Vancouver you
flew back I got in a car drove to the
top of America you did that drove back
well I actually walked across the border
and then walked back and got it
thank God they fucking the and
the fucking um
agent that worked at the board or is a
fan of the podcast the only reason I
fucking got the only reason I got back
she went Batman and I was like okay
we're fucking good the one person in
Canada that listens and you drove back
over the border to the airport and then
went to the you had a rental car to go
get that it was like uh like uh not an
Uber but it was like a car service
helped us right go across come back
because it had it been had it been any
other car I'm not allowed to bring a car
into the country girl so you got some
real how about this the car parked on
the Canada side and I walked to the
America side and then walked back like
fucking handmaid's tale you know how to
deal with some stuff
after not sleeping after working in that
car getting up going there with me the
easy thing's hard and the hard things
are a walk in the fucking Park after
you've done it was a walk in the park
you were kind of losing it a little over
here for 12 years that's amazing
colleges connections driving the fuck in
the middle of nowhere yeah getting to a
venue your body's just like oh this
getting to a casino and then finding out
it is an Indian Child burial ground and
then I what do I do with that
information I'm not staying here
there's a lot of choices we have to
fucking handle as witches
um I guess we're I'm gonna let you go
but I really did want to get into the
focus group theory that I have yes
please oh yeah
what else do we not close up though
coconuts and testing
oh really quick about Switching gears so
remember when you said I can't believe
you're saying that because it's the
inverse like the negative yeah and we're
on some Russian doll shit right now yeah
I believe this Theory Stay With Me
everything I've never learned how to do
I think this applies to everyone I'm
just saying I I think everything we've
all never learned how to do we already
do
example
we haven't learned how to do the thing
in
um
uh IRL in a micro level because we're
already doing it on macro level I have
never learned how to drive stick shift
in a car I don't know how
but in life all I do is switch gears
but I don't know how to drive stick
shift metaphorical
so what what else in your life do you
not know how to do do you know how to
play tennis
no exactly but that's all you do in
Improv
so you know how to play tennis more than
anyone you just can't do it with the
fucking dumb racket
you could apply that to anything I know
whoa did I just blow your mind whoa
whoa I need to hold that I need to get
on Etsy I need to I need some Jam hold
on I need a poncho the Crux of your shit
because you go I don't know how to do
this I don't know how to do this you do
you're just doing it on a grand scale
and not on some bullshit Hobby Lobby
motherfucker
name one other thing you can't do
any kind of hobby from Hobby Lobby
I can't you can wait in the Hobby Lobby
Braille I can't read Braille oh that's a
good one great but what you uh go ahead
read Braille yeah that means you can't
talk to blind people
done why would you brow
you know what you're tricky me now that
doesn't fit into your metaphor okay
you're doing it on the you're not giving
me okay so oh you didn't like what I
gave you do you even like the example
you can't read what blind people you're
you can't understand what blind people
are saying
I can't read the oh you know what you
did get me because the thing that's a
maybe I don't need I don't know you're
the blind person in this exchange I'm
the blind right now
so that's true
I'm not that's what I do
I can't uh say what I'm thinking or
feeling right now I can't read Braille
I'm lost I'm blind I'm walking through
life blind blind people are lost that
often they have a dog
if you follow that on Instagram the
blind people with their seeing eye dogs
oh it's the best who's filming them
their boyfriend
there's a guy filming the blind people
is filming him with his um dog
okay the blind person knows they're
being filmed oh yeah he talks to camera
oh okay he's showing us this is how I
live like like a slice of Life he's not
blonde and blind and that's okay but he
might be blind Never Gonna slip I'm
never going to sleep okay
yeah I got a little lost on your tennis
thing did you get lost Pat he's gonna
say he didn't because this makes sense
reading Braille is a tricky one does so
let me okay well because she was trying
to apply to anything
you can't read Braille why that's
correct why would you need to
yeah but your thing is that you're
already doing it but you're saying I'm
giving a bad example no you're nothing
you've done is wrong uh I'm not being
clear so no you're right okay I don't
need Braille is only between blind and
blind those are the only people that
need to communicate via Braille if we're
over here learning Braille we either are
only doing it as a teacher so we have to
scrap that as an example to your
metaphor don't use it as a count against
you you don't need to know it I'm
building up your self-esteem let's go I
don't even care about it what else I was
trying to think of an example I should
bring you if you didn't care about it I
know you're like fighting me I'm not
fighting you well it's not a fight it's
more like it's okay that you you're
trying to tell me it's okay that I don't
know
foreign
I feel like I'm tripping right now it's
kind of fun that's my personality dude
this is good so what else can't you do
how am I gonna come down from this when
I leave what do you suggest the first
thing you said was after I've been with
you and I leave it's like what do I do
what a warm bath I put on this outfit
and then I'll I'll be able to come down
yes and you that's your
so take a quick hit of that weird butter
no you don't you'd rather just eat
Sbarro in the airport because that's the
other thing anything you buy in the gift
shops when you travel you can eat it on
your way back
have you ever heard of jam have you ever
been in an airport and gotten yourself a
fucking bagel and been like I have some
homemade Elderberry Jam right fucking
here no I'm gonna eat this at the food
court well everyone else is getting
cancer
I'm gonna redistribute the wealth and
eat Pure Nutrients
please mute my pass this is wild what a
wild example of the Elderberry Jam
I'm definitely down a hallway in your
brain right now
why do we here I have a question for you
Cam Archer wrote a script brilliant
strip was script about remember Kathy
yes absolutely and he wants me to play
Kathy so the real life Kathy
I think I should do it
do you know about Kathy yeah yeah she's
and she's a little bit downtrodden shot
right yeah
before memes we had comic straps her
vibe is like I Don't Like Mondays she's
a single lady right loves a cat he loves
Garfield
so
this is her she's like where's where's
my coffee bathing suit never fits I
gotta get ready for bathing suit season
right I'm embarrassed this was her in
real life
wait what she's gorgeous gorgeous and
thin
okay this is the lady that wrote the yes
and sorry one of my glasses and look at
right late night paint your blind I know
we've been through this
um late night
look at her on The Tonight Show with
Johnny Carson or Leno she would go on
she won an Emmy oh my God I love her she
would go on these appearances on TV she
won an Emmy yeah but her whole thing is
she had body dysmorphia and oh my gosh
you gotta do this she saw herself as
like fat
but also like who knows right right she
looks fucking we look exactly alike look
Pat kind of I mean
yeah you could pull that off okay and
she's like tiny though and this guy
can't and it's about like a like a dream
kind of thing I want to like give it to
Byron Allen to maybe make or something
but like I don't know who would make it
but or pay for it
um because this fucking business doesn't
make movies that are good they just want
to make the like fucking weird ass shit
for China that they won't even watch do
you know about little Ellen
I was visiting China recently and I came
across little Allen and I said what the
little Ellen okay this is a
um show an animated show based based on
Ellen DeGeneres okay so this is a cash
grab is what you're saying
hi Michael Schneider and welcome to
varieties Awards circuit where this time
out we're analyzed
fuck you hold on you guys tricked me
fuck you man I'm glad I screen grabbed
this and I'm gonna go to my I left two
14 year olds at home to do this part
when I called them just now you saw how
handsome they were the dog was you're
just like don't care about little Ellen
it's wild I'm trying to block Lil Ellen
out dude is it Lil Lil it's an animated
show about Ellen
two seasons were made I really hate that
animation okay
I'm starting to figure out why Ann Hayes
drove into a house I think she saw this
poster
okay
and this is
hahaha I would have driven to a house
too if my ex-wife who jumped into a
volcano just gets to turn straight
[Music]
okay
man shit so so Ellen did a a show called
little L and it's animated it's about
her and um the showrunner's quote was
Ellen was less than zero percent
involved Less Than Zero
what's little Ellen about is it Ellen as
a child it was obviously made for China
because you know what Ellen's show is
called in China and I think this is why
she's always in such a bad mood
what's the show you know in China Two
Broke Girls is not called tuber girls in
China right it's like two Tomatoes this
show is just her name
you think China would do that they call
it dancing lady
well I was gonna say lesbian lady yeah I
didn't want to say that lesbian lady
they can't have lesbians right correct
correct correct dancing I mean they
barely let girls survive their straight
after they're born yeah little Ellen
little dancing Ellen
dancing lady in trousers
were you at the bird Crusher roast you
were yeah did you see the whole rant I
did about Alan
am I said did you see myself yes
I kind of defend Ellen for like 20
seconds and then what'd you say
um
like in um Hollywood like that like
being a boss like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
because for a guy to be canceled as a
male boss yes 18 interns have to
complain about the button under your
desk remember you saying that but as a
woman leader you just have to like you
just can't be like a grump yeah like how
Ellen like how did she how does someone
abuse you if you can't look them in the
eye
like I'm with you I'm on your side but
let's just like
if she's dancing yeah she's little she's
so little they're anger on Anger of
having to do that would be rough I would
get angry if I had to like dance
literally tap dance I agree with what
you're saying like but I don't I don't
know I wasn't there but that's probably
the reason probably was a terrible what
are you saying just quit I think anyone
that has over a hundred thousand dollars
cash has no excuse to ever have bad
behavior ever there's no excuse oh yeah
I thought you were talking about her
you're saying her she has no excuse
enough no one no one that is that I I
like I'm throwing this around it should
probably be less less but like a hundred
thousand dollars cash in your bank
account you have no excuse to ever be
fucking rude to anyone
but usually people are more Rude the
more money they have I know
not about the money them yeah but
they're not they're they're in trouble
online let's go buy some stuff from Etsy
do you want to see how many things I
bought from Etsy since 11AM yes today
since 11 A.M
okay look so since 11 A.M okay organic
Turkish towel got it what color uh
purple
rock star table all rock stars okay uh
like decoupage now when you buy
something like a side table do you have
somewhere you're gonna put it or not
sure who it's for yeah
girl maybe it's like a maybe like I buy
things and I go I know someone's gonna
need that so this is yours
um is it purchases and reviews so I buy
things and then later so this table my
sister moving her into a new place side
table her and I are Yin and Yang it's a
good reminder for us that we're wildly
different but super complimentary had to
have this uh for my sister's new place
and probably for me too it's a door mat
what does it say check your energy
we're here
get used to it this is a side table that
has electric outlets in it cute side
table
side table yeah
are you listening did you ever get that
wicker one the lick the Wicker um the oh
look at those two isn't it khaki they're
getting some work they're like no
getting's not that's not
okay Mary Lynn and I speaking of Yin and
Yang look at this side look how useful
this fucking thing is you put it on the
side of your couch and it holds shit
it's like a little it's like a doily
that holds computer
it's it works it's a caddy it's genius
it's a caddy it's a genius caddy it's a
it's a doily caddy finally everything
will be organized Shark Tank finally
everything has a place everything's out
of place a bunch of hooks you know about
me and my hooks gotta have my hooks wall
hooks Mountain hooks
it's very cute you gotta have hooks
you know what I'm saying
um I'm gonna have you open your present
and then I'm gonna uh release you from
this nightmare fever dream you're in
um here's your present
hold on don't open it yet listen listen
the fuck up
oh that's a good terracotta pot
don't you fucking dick I'm not looking
okay I'm just touching it but now I can
see it are we engaged
um deeper than that it's deeper than
that
you know what hold on listen listen to
me look at me open your eyes see you are
you are blind you try to be blind
okay so we're in a jam we're in a jam ah
is this this is why I was right stop
stop reading Braille stop reading
Braille you won't know what it is so you
might it's terms because you can read
Braille so we do we are in a jam and uh
I just want to go on record saying to
you uh I was right about what about the
Wicker
um uh what it's worth the Walker Turtle
pan planter thousand dollars it's been
sold it's gone
I'm so sorry we didn't buy it when we
should have was it in your likes is that
how you go back to it like how did you
know how maybe they shipped it and it
got lost in the mail because it's not
like me to not have purchased that I
know you know I did go and Prozac around
that time so maybe I controlled myself
what do you mean you were not on Prozac
before that I was but it was like it
takes four months to kick in and you
know what else I just went off birth
control for the first time in 25 years
I've been on birth control so for those
of you wondering why my brain is working
fast and I'm not like a fucking zombie
oh well there's no Turtle thing
maybe I didn't need it maybe it wasn't
meant for me oh that's why I went off on
this lady in the audience
oh really she's like but what was she
doing she might have deserved I don't I
don't like kids okay yeah uh go off yeah
you she goes I just take the morning
after pill but I was asked I didn't ask
I was asking for something funny was she
trying to she was trying
she wasn't even trying to be funny she
was trying to be close that's very close
she was just like clap back like you
know when people are like I have
attitude for days and I'm going to show
you like a very awesome immature
insecure now with Twitter and Facebook
and comments everyone thinks when a
comedian is talking with a microphone
there's two or three people in each
audience going
she can't wait to hear what I think
about this yeah I'm gonna help this show
I'm gonna help they think the show is
this wasn't this was an offshoot of
helping I did ask for I think you got in
the car for them I asked her for
something very simple which was hey like
just to include you hey right and she
went
I don't hmm I go what do you need oh no
white and naturally blonde
nope
not white
and dark hair
okay
so and then she might have been right
black women come to your shows now I'm
so jealous she wasn't black
but she wasn't white think about it it
was little Ellen okay
little Ellen was it Tamron Hall she was
dancing but it was aggressive
we never got to my testing thing it's
okay we'll get to it eventually
I just have two ideas I want I want to
make you laugh so we're gonna get to it
right now what's the test no we can't
it's 3 30. I can't do I I'm starting to
Fort podcast that I'm doing four hours I
gotta get down to an hour and I swear
can you open that gift please yeah I
don't know if you'll wear it I mean
looking at what's around your neck you
might
so
I am into charm bracelets right now and
this is a charm bracelet from like the
40s
and you know me I'm a fucking cowgirl
bitch have you seen Yellowstone
no okay I can't watch it because of the
horses it's always abuse when horses are
in things but you know how many horses
are too sensitive Whitney this is so
sweet thank you somebody put on for you
it's Gonna Make some noise but do you
see what the charm do you want me to put
the poncho on too
um
so is it gonna fit on my fat wrist hold
on real quick though so there is one see
Cowboy we love Cowboys this is how we
manifest Cowboys
this is the one problematic charm which
is like a Native American dancing I I
don't it might not be problematic I
don't know you'd have to I'm just gonna
call that one little Ellen cow very
important
um saddle cowgirl hat
uh this one I don't love but it's fine
that's a mule remember your drug mule so
that's already fit and cowgirl boot keep
keep Dancing Yeah it's better no it's
not oh okay get above the bone whoa you
doubt it look at this you might even
want to take a couple uh rings out of it
or uh links out of it thank you so much
this is so sweet
um okay I feel close to you the accused
I I'm glad actually that we didn't talk
too much about it because now you'll
have stuff to talk about on fucking all
the talk shows because we're gonna be
doing press and we're going to be we're
gonna be doing so much like are you
going on a bunch of podcasts in January
for this
I like doing you should do tiger belly
Natasha leggero's oh they have me
um uh santinos yeah let's we'll just
text him right now santinos
um
um
your mom's house yeah your mom's house
but it's in Austin oh yeah but sometimes
they come back here Christina peas
uh where my mom's at but that I think is
definitely in Austin
I'll go to Austin yeah I'll pop up me
too I think I'm gonna go in the end of
um January I haven't done the to do
Rogan kill Tony and hopefully your mom's
house you're doing that for the accused
yeah that's awesome I think I always
bomb your mom's house I've I've bombed
it like twice so now I have to go back
and like
but it wasn't there it wasn't anyone's
fault it's just I think that there was a
time there when I would go on podcasts
and Comics thought they had to ask me
about like Hollywood like so you you
created these shows I'm like can we
please talk about dicks and farts
like Ivan you know what I mean but I
think that on podcasts there was a time
where when I would go on everyone
thought they had asked me like about my
career they were asking about your
career and what as they should because
it was like
you know what I mean what else that's
what we were just talking about in the
beginning I think when we first started
podcast we all took the bad data from
like oh this is a new late night talk
show so we have to like ask more
questions and the audience doesn't give
a shit
they just want us to be funny and dumb
or sincere and vulnerable
right you know and we were like yeah I
got a show made and here's and they're
like who gives a fuck but I didn't want
to say like can I not answer this
sometimes when I'm on stage if I go like
dark or deep or something too fast
people are just like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa or even if like I have a little bit
that I'll do especially if I feel like
it's a we can't open like this is like
I'll do a thing about being an actor
I'll mention the shows and then people
will be like Yay she said my thing and
then I'll shift and they're like don't
worry me out don't bum me out what
happens we're entertainers like it take
me a long time to learn we're
entertainers people are paying 80
fucking bucks maybe more they are not
coming to see us be like because I have
depression they're like you're supposed
to make me happier I have depression for
real right you know what I mean I've had
to learn that way but I'm not saying
like all my stuff that's a little bit I
love you happy and there's jokes but
that's what's more interesting to me
always but it my thing is always order
and who's in the audience like reading
if it's just a random night at the
fucking
what where are we every single night
it's hard though when I'm running sets
especially in La like on the road
obviously it's my show but if they want
to see like Chloe from 24 I will give
them yes a good however long it takes
they didn't pay you 80 just for you so
it was like it's like if you're paying
20 bucks to go to The Comedy Store but
you really want to see Trevor Wallace
and then I come on being like abort I
had an abortion and was molested blah
and if you don't think it's funny like
that's fine you didn't pay me the 80 to
put on the show for you that's the truth
I'm there to work out right there
exactly that's the trip about running
spots in LA because it's like well I
don't want to take five to seven minutes
of my set that's only 15 minutes I
already know these work to do like hey
24 this and that it's like I want to do
now I have to say it I'm here to work
out these are new jokes if you want to
go to the bathroom now's your time
because this is if you want to see a
jokes see me at the well turn or watch a
special but like I'm at the gym I think
that people when they come to the comedy
that's a good idea but then you'll see
Sebastian come on and be at the gym with
brand new shit and looks polished so
it's like
sometimes it'll work sometimes it won't
but you're watching us experiment yeah
and I think that that's something and
honestly now that we're talking about it
it usually is great it's usually is my
ego that I want to be like probably my
ego that I want to be crushing at the
beginning when it was at The Comedy
Store it was like dude I used to follow
Joey Diaz I would Pace on the I would
stretch I was like I I don't even know
if a shit is going to work here like
Rogan
um fucking uh uh Bobby Lee would go
before before he would do 9 30 and then
fucking Joey Diaz and then me and then
jeselnick and I was like I'm glad to
hear you say this because I see you as
impenetrable so that's nice that's why I
am but that energy is so high
yeah the building would shake when Joey
came the building would Shake Mountain
you motherfucker he would take his balls
out and then and then so I was like this
is how you become this is why The Comedy
Store makes us you're a comedy store
comic the people that are only doing
other venue even the seller in New York
I'm sorry I love the seller it's not
that hard of a room
like it's not that hard I haven't done
that I've only done it like once on time
it's a blast the one around the corner
is a little bit and it depends on the
night if you're going up after Chris
Rock just popped in to run his Oscar set
you better fucking you better not try to
do a jokes you better just lean against
the wall and be like okay and just talk
about Chris Rock like when you follow
Sebastian you only the only way to get
laughs following Sebastian
and Joey is to just go remember when
Sebastian talked about that that was
hilarious right they they can't even
they don't have to come down from it
move on they're not moving they're not
going to move on we just go remember
what you just saw let's relive it yeah
that's the only way until you're out of
it and I can talk about something until
they're like oh and who are you yeah
until they're done looking at the photos
they took like they're just
it's wild are you guys ready for a lady
I did follow uh Rick Ingram in the main
room the other night which is Big
amazing and I did that I tried
I know this was like he was just back in
town the freedom in but the fact that I
could do it in the main room and I did
new shit which was unformed like that
Dad stuff it was I felt really good even
though I was like my mouth was dry and
I'm like I'm not like that room is so
big that is like someone's water skiing
at 80 miles an hour and you jumped on
and fucking took over like that's the
feeling of that yeah like doing a
backflip on a fucking horse in the
circus while it's running that's like
how the fuck did I get that but that's
something that only comedy story that's
La Jolla Comedy Store
but that's an interesting metaphor
because like can you Ma sometimes you
can't force yourself to match an energy
that either you're not at or either like
you they it has to adjust to you
whatever you chase you chase away you
Just Surrender yeah and go I'm only
gonna do 50 and I'm just gonna because
it's like yeah you're jumping on a
moving boat yeah you know I mean you
can't you have no control or else you're
gonna stop the vibe and you're gonna
break the spell you're gonna break the
because like it's our job to to cast a
spell yeah and to create this Flow State
and the transition it's like handing the
Baton off that's where you fuck it up
yeah you have to make sure it's smooth
or else people go I'm watching comedy oh
they gotta stay like it's it's who's
gonna break
the smooth Flow State of hypnot of us
hypnotizing people and I guess being on
with all those big uh legendary big
energy
is you have to find your own way to
match that and you know who is I was
through yourself that's the hardest
person to follow the comedy store right
now
Whitney Cummings Argus Hamilton
he has been around since like the 70s
yeah mitzi's like pick I'm never there
because he goes on early I always get
there always go after him he would do 9
30 spot I used to open for him in La
Jolla and he's older and he kind of like
reads like topical jokes he has top new
topics but he sets up that rhythm
good because right now at a time where
everyone's too afraid because everyone's
trying to be PC he's just like Argus and
he's going on and he goes uh you know
and he said he like goes to church for
real yeah you know does he really yeah I
know that and he goes and he does like a
lecture about Calvinism for like 10
minutes that destroys even though no one
understands what he's talking about he's
such a pro I've never seen the lecture
on camera I mean he's also like look I'm
sober you know yes I look I do not like
I did cocaine 30 years I Don't Like
Cocaine I just like the smell of it you
know I mean it's just like you're just
everyone's like God women have those
classes and then he goes like at my
church I just want you to know I am
pro-gay marriage I am not homophobic I
believe that there can be same sex
marriages any time I firmly believe that
as long as they're the same race
it just
it just murders the timing's perfect
it's just like the greatest
to watch he's just like the audience is
just like
no one's like he's not going I don't
want to get canceled for saying this and
everyone's like
can you not even bring that up and just
fucking they're all formatted in that
really tight and he's earned and his the
timing got like it's just Funk the
silences are perfect he moves it's just
masterful what are you doing
bye-bye those glasses thank you for my
gift they don't work on camera anywhere
I love these glasses do they work
oh tip for me help me see yeah do we
need to do the Braille thing it's
unclear wait I'm sorry who are you
um Sarah Silverman oh thank you for
having me Pete I wish
thank you for having me I love you yeah
maybe you can pop in when maybe you can
we can do around two when Sean's here
and we can dig more after it's aired and
answer questions from the audience
together because I feel like we want to
give away a lot of spoilers so I'm
trying to like not oh my gosh let me
come in and I'll let him talk but I'll
I'll just be here yeah me and you will
talk um with Sean about like every scene
will break uh down like how we do I'm
like the third wheel to your guys's rape
that's so sweet it was a threesome you
can rape in the three right I topped
both of y'all what's up
we did direct your life we did what's
worse than napping you we're just
ignoring you for day when we had to do
the rape scene I know we were like oh
how about this hold on last thing last
thing okay Sean I we are shooting a
scene upstairs I am really close with
Mary at this point right both Comics
sisters I'm like I found a new sister
you were going through stuff with your
mom I was like she's my new sister then
I meet Sean and I'm like oh my God Sean
this guy used to be a comic he's I'm
married to a gynecologist we're about to
do this intimate scene I haven't now I
have a chosen brother like holy shit
but they kind of don't really
I don't know they're not jowing and then
I'm sitting outside eating one day
neither of them are working at the time
they're called times like 8 P.M I'm
working like a fucking dog in a mini
skirt eat trying to eat beans like while
getting kova tested and I don't know me
that I act like this and Laverne and
Shirley
so around the corner they're skipping
they're both skipping like fucking
Mayberry
crackheads they're skipping hand in hand
dying laughing that was a good day
they're like they have inside joke
they're like and that's why he said it
was like Roger Beth
and then everyone's like what the fuck
happened they like went and got a drink
and became best friends and it was very
annoying
I love your annoyance I was like I love
your act out at work okay I'm over here
acting guys playing my playlist it
wasn't enough The Beautiful People
crying so much crying you were an
emotional wreck I was crying the entire
time but the problem am I saying what a
brilliant
um dramatic actor they cut out all my
snot it was a lot of snot I would do
like no but I would do like an awesome
take that was like I totally felt it it
felt real and I gave everything I had
and she'd be like can you do it again
with just no snot and I was like no no I
don't think and then I had to try to do
it again I was like I didn't know that I
was like I just need 10 minutes to just
do it again and what about our scene
together at the table
doing the nail polish
I was having a moment I also think
usually I can't I was being objective I
was like look we were really in it I
know and then the scene where you threw
the thing at
um the guy and I believe how much he
loves you and you guys are friends and
that we would like do his name and be
like are you okay I'm sorry like it was
so wild oh here we go spoiler I don't
think we can show that ah yes that's
cool
sorry why not I mean it's fine look at
her hands she's a maniac let me see that
oh yes that's awesome see how Pat um
split screen them that that never
happened he put him in he put us on the
same side yeah because there's like
eight hands down there
remember remember when I dropped the
glass and we had that like a little cute
improv moment yes it was like the best
go back okay so I love um being with you
on set because you're back so into it
and you love it this photo was I don't
even know when that was fucking oh yeah
remember when they took our so girl
that's really good you do the third
drama I thought it was gonna be they
were gonna make you like it was four in
the morning
but I didn't I didn't get to my stock
photo until four in the morning and I
looked like myself sexual member and I
had no makeup and I had just been crying
all day and they're like time for your
photo and I'm like my face was swollen
this is what's gonna be out of billboard
look at the lashes I sound like such a
narcissist but they cleaned it up with
they did some photoshop or something I
mean look at my skin it looks like um it
looks like pound cake
that's the style of the whole thing what
do you mean it has nothing to do with
the makeup on your face look at the
whole picture over pixels look at his
eyes bright blue look at Abigail Breslin
I'm excited about hers yeah me too I
can't wait to see all the episodes this
one is I know Rachel Bilson is coming on
in like two weeks I don't know what her
episode's about but checklist is what
his is about is a wild
I think it's in the realm of if you know
your child's going to be a school
shooter what do you do oh dang um it's
like on some of my Dimension how many
episodes are there six I want to say
because it was based on there was an
English format that was yes like Israeli
is it English oh maybe I don't I think
24 was maybe Israeli but um maybe both
and about uh we have to go I thank you
for having me I love you don't run
elephants
I love uh acting with you we're gonna do
it again and seeing you on set was
exciting it's a dream because you're
really into it I think you're like a
child enjoying your craft acting careers
I think are ahead of us I think we were
designed to be like I only wanted from
your lips to
from you from your lips to Howard
Gordon's ass
think it happens to the casting director
your lips let's go baby I'm gonna go to
Niagara Falls oh my gosh oh you're doing
stand up yes do you want to come and we
can see the other side when are you at
the end of January I'm doing Niagara
Falls that might be when I go to the
American side hell yeah I do oh that
might be when I'm at sketchfest oh
that's right is it the very last week or
the week 20 uh it's like yeah about last
weekend and then I do Atlantic City
that would be the best we're back we're
back I love you don't ride elephants I
end these very awkwardly Maryland
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]